We all know Hagrid is the paragon of gentle
giants.
But can the same be said for the late actor
who played him – Robbie Coltrane?
HBO Max rang in 2022 with an incredible release
for fans, debuting a "Harry Potter" reunion
special featuring all of your favorite actors
and plenty of reminiscing about what it was
like to make this epic eight-film franchise.
In particular, the younger set of actors who
grew up on the set had a lot of revelations
about what it was like to work with the adult
cast members, many of whom are some of the
most decorated performers in British film
and television history.
From Maggie Smith to Helena Bonham Carter
to actors who sadly passed away like Richard
Harris, Richard Griffiths, and Alan Rickman,
the then-child actors had the opportunity
to work with some of the best living actors
of their time.
Chris Columbus, director of the first two
"Potter" movies, tells audiences during the
reunion:
"I don't think any of the kids had the capability
of understanding the gravity of who they were
dealing with at the time.
The British royalty of the acting world."
Among those giant names, one person got a
ton of shoutouts — Coltrane, who shared
a ton of scenes with Radcliffe, Watson, and
Grint in particular.
Watson recalled.
"The adult actors came in and were, like,
the mischief, in a funny way."
Speaking specifically about Coltrane, Grint
said:
"He was such a kid, like, so immature and
like, just so much fun."
Radcliffe, accompanied by a video of Coltrane
doing a super-silly voice, said:
"He loved making us laugh, and he was incredibly
good at it."
After that, the reunion brought Watson and
Coltrane together, who shared a hug and snapped
a photo before reminiscing about their time
on set.
As Watson pointed out, the two spent a lot
of time together filming in Hagrid's hut,
and Coltrane even admitted that he probably
saw the trio more than his own children.
Even after twenty years, the bond between
Coltrane and the trio was as strong as ever,
and his, as Watson points out, "warmth and
kindness" made all of the difference for the
young actors.
Daniel Radcliffe felt so comfortable on the
"Harry Potter" sets with Robbie Coltrane initially
that he decided to prank his co-star.
When appearing on "The Rosie O'Donnell Show"
in the early aughts, Coltrane told the talk
show host about how Radcliffe got a hold of
his phone and made some adjustments, so he
had no idea how to work it.
A very young Radcliffe was there as the story
was told and couldn't help but chuckle.
Coltrane remembered:
"This one here turned the language on my cellular
phone into Turkish."
He then laughed that it would've been easy
to switch it back to English, but you must
know Turkish to do that.
According to Hollywood.com, Radcliffe felt
terrible about the prank afterward and wrote
Coltrane a note to apologize.
These types of interviews and the HBO Max
"Harry Potter" reunion special prove just
how special the late Coltrane was to the rest
of the cast and the fans of the franchise.
Coltrane said:
"The legacy of the movies is that my children's
generation will show them to their children,
so you could be watching it in 50 years' time
— easy."
And then, just to make sure no one is exempt
from shedding at least one tear, he poignantly
concluded:
"I'll not be here, sadly…"
"...but Hagrid will.
Yes."